we all have to remember this central
question is
love truly blind ever wonder what they
didn't show on netflix love is blind and
what the contestants went through after
the show aired
while netflix hit show gave us a glimpse
into the contestants lives during the
experiment
it didn't show everything what was
filming this show really like
and what were some of the challenges
everyone faced after the show and
what are they up to now stay tuned to
see what netflix didn't
show during and after love is blind
wrapped
camera yes i think i love you
i love you contestants giannina
and damian made falling in love through
a wall seem effortless
even though they didn't make it to i do
on the show giannina said in an
interview with e that she felt like he
was reading my mind through a wall
at the reunion it's shown that the two
are dating and that they're still
together to this day
in the same interview damien said that
the pressure of being on a tv show
affected his
i don't and that he didn't want them to
feel locked down due to the show's
demand for a wedding
one of the show's success stories lauren
and cameron share on their youtube
channel hanging with the hamiltons that
once the show aired dealing with
newfound fame put some pressure on their
life as a married couple
and business partners giannina and
damien are in a similar boat where
damien shares that they had to sit down
and talk about what their future
together would look like
they concluded that they were aware of
the challenges they were about to face
but
they felt like it was worth it i said
look no matter what happens
we leave this together and she's like
yeah we do it is revealed in the reunion
episode that diamond is working on her
phd
and jessica has started therapy other
contestants have made positive changes
to their lives too mark is engaged and
according to his instagram
expecting their first child cameron and
lauren recently discussed their plans to
get their own studio
along with looking for a new home also
giannina went through a lot of
self-discovery and also
many jobs trying to figure out herself
and what she wanted to do
never give up two individuals from
season one have admitted to their lives
being changed for the worse during the
reunion diamond admitted to getting
threats via online from
fans of the show going as far as to call
her biphobic
and homophobic she shared how hard it's
been since the show aired but continues
to keep moving forward
her former fiance carlton admitted he's
had his own sheriff online hate
after the mexico trip played out he
confesses that he feels
so misunderstood during that scene and
that he feels he's been wrongly judged
brings you to a very dark space one of
the show's few married couples
barnett and amber share their struggles
once they went back to normal life
in an interview with harper's bazaar the
pair admitted that they had trouble
adjusting to life after filming
amber who was open with barnett about
her financial troubles since before
their wedding
said that her not having a job was
putting strain on her husband
she eventually found work as a cocktail
waitress the two
shared it was difficult adjusting to
going out as a married couple as opposed
to their single life before the show
amber said that she was close to hiring
a divorce attorney at one point
it's been a wild ride i'd say currently
there's a season two
and a season three in the works
according to an article from netflix
life season two is slated for 2021
the release date is still not confirmed
they're casting around the chicago area
as opposed to atlanta like the first
season
carlton from season one has expressed
heavy interest in being on season two
hoping to find love the second time
around given that there is supposed to
be a heavier focus on more fluid people
there's no fear involved in love even
though the interactions on the show
were genuine for the most part there was
still a heavy influence from the
producers
jessica knew she wasn't going to marry
mark but the producers wouldn't let her
leave before the ceremony
things were really you know going the
way that i hoped
that they would also there were couples
who ended up engaged but weren't shown
on the show
in an interview with people magazine
rory newbrow
and wesley bear said that the producers
came to them after the proposals and
told them they didn't have the budget to
cover all the couples
given how intense and unique the setup
was in the pods the cast had to figure
out how to adjust to communicating with
each other in person
jessica admitted that communicating in
the pods versus outside of them was a
huge barrier for her and mark
because while in the pods everyone is on
and once the couples got engaged and
started spending time together they had
to adjust their expectations and
communication styles
we never talked about poop
as with most reality shows editing can
really make or break our perceptions of
contestants
damien said that everything we saw on
the show isn't everything that was
happening
and the audience didn't get to see a lot
of the beautiful moments where the
couples were enjoying their time
together
also we didn't get to know kenny and
kelly until the mexico trip which was an
interesting choice for the producers to
make
it was hard to emotionally invest in a
couple that seemed so solid to the point
of being
a bit boring but they proved everyone
wrong by ultimately
not getting married i can't marry you
and i hope that you can appreciate that
as mentioned earlier some of the
dramatic scenes of the weddings were a
result of productions pressure
like kenny's long instagram post saying
that he and kelly already agreed they
wouldn't get married
and that it was all an act on the
wedding day producer chris coelhan went
on record
saying that the post was kenny's way of
saving face and it is authentic
and it is real but today is is not our
day
in an interview with entertainment
weekly jessica admitted she tried to
leave the show earlier than she did
saying i mean i had to stay i definitely
had a conversation about leaving and
i wasn't able to do that i'm just happy
that i was able to participate in an
experiment where
this does work out the question that's
on everyone's minds
what couples made it through the
experiment and are still together
as mentioned before lord and cameron are
still happily married and are stronger
than ever
like if we get married i have to get a
puppy despite their hardships at the
beginning of their marriage
amber and barnette are still with each
other a house was haunted y'all
not a fan while they didn't get married
on the show
giannina and damian are still dating
we're soul mates
in addition to helping the cast find
true love the show has also provided a
launch pad for new opportunities and
careers
cameron and lauren hamilton have their
first book coming out called
leap of faith an autobiographical
recounting of their love story
diamond has her own reality show that
she hosts online called
faraway bay where she goes on a series
of virtual dates over the week
eliminating someone each night in hopes
of finding her true love
mark and fiance aubry rainey recently
started their own youtube channel called
catching up with the cuevas love is
blind
season one down in the books as with
most reality series
if there's an opportunity for a spin-off
series it usually happens
given the popularity of the hamiltons
hanging with the hamilton's youtube
channel
it wouldn't be out of the question for
their show to be picked up by netflix at
some point
i'm gonna take over the world bunny and
clyde style
the rumors surrounding this idea is that
netflix has been considering a spin-off
series featuring the popular couple
amber shared a photo on her instagram of
several cast members hanging out at a
show event in atlanta
however not everyone from the show is on
good terms
we saw in the reunion that jessica and
amber still have a wedge between them
i think you were a very disingenuous
person and it's since been revealed that
diamond blocked carlton on her social
media again
despite the reconciliation we saw in the
show in an interview with tmz she shared
that she blocked him because he was
disrespecting her on his social media
after the reunion barnett shares that
he's gotten some attention from huge
stars like justin bieber and kim
kardashian
him and amber also received an
invitation from a-lister millie bobby
brown for her 16th birthday party
unfortunately due to covet 19 the party
was canceled
overall the feedback the cast has gotten
from celebs has been mostly positive
it's all becoming real it's becoming
very real
love is blind fans what do you think has
this made you look at the show and the
possibilities of reality tv differently
let us know in the comments